>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>>> ALL RIGHT, WE DO HAVE
BREAKING NEWS.
THE RUSSIANS CLAIMING THEY'RE
GOING TO REDUCE MILITARY
ACTIVITY IN TWO KEY AREAS AROUND
THE CAPITAL OF KYIV AND ALSO
NORTHEAST OF THAT IN CHERNIHIV.
I WANT TO READ YOU A FULL
STATEMENT FROM THE DEPUTY
DEFENSE MINISTER, AND WHAT IS
NOTABLE IN THIS IS THAT THIS
STATEMENT WAS MADE AFTER THE
CURRENT ROUND OF NEGOTIATIONS
TAKING PLACE BETWEEN THE
RUSSIANS AND UKRAINIANS IN
ISTANBUL.
SO LISTEN TO THIS.
HE SAID, QUOTE, DUE TO THE FACT
THAT NEGOTIATIONS ON THE
PREPARATION OF AN AGREEMENT ON
THE NEUTRALITY AND NONNUCLEAR
STATUS OF UKRAINE AS WELL AS ON
THE PROVISION OF NUCLEAR
GUARANTEES TO UKRAINE ARE MOVING
INTO PRACTICE, TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT THE PRINCIPLES DISCUSSED
DURING TODAY'S MEETINGS BY THE
MINISTRY OF DEFENSE OF THE
RUSSIAN FEDERATION IN ORDER TO
INCREASE MUTUAL TRUST AND CREATE
NECESSARY CONDITIONS FOR FURTHER
NEGOTIATIONS AND ACHIEVING THE
ULTIMATE GOAL OF AGREEING ON THE
SIGNING OF THE ABOVE AGREEMENT,
A DECISION WAS MADE TO RADICALLY
AT TIMES REDUCE MILITARY
ACTIVITY IN THE KYIV AND
CHERNIHIV REGIONS.
AGAIN, THAT STATEMENT FROM THE
RUSSIAN DEPUTY DEFENSE MINISTER.
I WANT TO BRING IN DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN ALISA SLOTKIN OF
MICHIGAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US, CONGRESSWOMAN.
IF YOU CAN HEAR ME, AND IF YOU
HEARD THAT STATEMENT, AND
FOLLOWING THIS DEVELOPMENT, I
WANT YOUR TAKE ON THAT.
>> YEAH.
WELL, LISTEN, IT IS POSITIVE,
BUT WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH THE
RUSSIANS, IT IS, YOU KNOW, IT IS
REAGAN, IT IS TRUST BUT VERIFY.
THE NUMBER OF TIMES IN THE
RECENT WEEKS THAT THEY HAVE
AGREED TO SOMETHING LIKE A
HUMANITARIAN CORRIDOR, WITH THE
UKRAINIANS AND THEN GONE AHEAD
AND BOMBED IT, WE NEED TO
ACTUALLY FOLLOW UP AND MAKE SURE
THEY'RE DOING IT.
SO IT IS A POSITIVE STEP, BUT
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE TO DO IT IN
ORDER TO CELEBRATE ANYTHING.
>> YEAH.
LOOK, ABSOLUTELY.
THE RUSSIANS HAVE REPEATEDLY
LIED AND I DON'T USE THAT WORD
LIGHTLY FROM BEFORE THE INVASION
THROUGH THE LAST SIX WEEKS AS
THEY HAVE BEEN STRIKING
CIVILIANS AND WHAT NOT ALL OVER
THIS COUNTRY.
STILL, NEVERTHELESS, THE
UKRAINIANS HAVEN'T PUSHED BACK
ON THIS NOTION.
THE UKRAINIANS ARE GIVING THE
SENSE THAT MORE -- THAT SOME
PROGRESS AT LEAST WAS MADE IN
THESE TALKS.
I WONDER WHAT YOUR HOPES ARE FOR
THE NEXT FEW DAYS.
>> I THOUGHT WHAT WAS
INTERESTING OUT OF THE
ANNOUNCEMENT, ONE, THAT THE
UKRAINIANS SEEM RIGHT NOW TO BE
CONFIRMING THE REPORTS, BUT
SECONDLY THERE WAS CLEARLY
DISCUSSION OF OTHER COUNTRIES,
INDIVIDUAL COUNTRIES PROVIDING
SOME SECURITY GUARANTEES TO THE
COUNTRY OF UKRAINE, RIGHT.
LOOKING AT THAT LIST, I THINK
THEY SAID CANADA OR TURKEY OR
ISRAEL, JUST LIKE AN INTERESTING
LIST OF COUNTRIES.
IT IS NOT NATO, RIGHT, IT IS
SOME MEMBERS IN NATO, IT IS SOME
THAT ARE NOT, SO I THINK IT IS
JUST AN INTERESTING DEVELOPMENT.
WE ALL KNEW THAT ONCE PUTIN WENT
IN AND INVADED LIKE THIS, HE
COMPLETELY CHANGED SECURITY IN
EUROPE, SECURITY FRANKLY
GLOBALLY.
AND WE KNEW THERE WAS GOING TO
BE A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS
HAPPENING AFTER THIS WAS FINALLY
RESOLVED AND I THINK WE'RE
SEEING INTERESTING DATA POINTS
OF JUST A VERY DIFFERENT
SECURITY ARCHITECTURE IN THAT
AREA.
>> LOOK, THERE IS A LOT OF NEW
INFORMATION COMING IN, WE'RE ALL
TRYING TO PROCESS IS, I
APPRECIATE YOU ROLLING WITH US
ON THIS, TRYING TO PROCESS IT AT
THE SAME TIME.
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON YOUR OWN
PROPOSALS ON SANCTIONS, AND THE
REASON I BRING THIS UP IS
BECAUSE THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY, THIS WAS ALL BEFORE
WHEREVER WE ARE AT THIS MOMENT
IN THE NEGOTIATIONS, BUT
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY'S CONCERNS
HAVE BEEN THAT THE SANCTIONS
AREN'T COMING QUICKLY ENOUGH.
WHAT HE BASICALLY SAID YESTERDAY
WAS THAT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THERE WILL BE MORE SANCTIONS IF
THERE IS A CHEMICAL WEAPONS
ATTACK.
WHY DO I HAVE TO WAIT, HE SAYS,
FOR A CHEMICAL WEAPONS ATTACK
FOR MORE SANCTIONS ON RUSSIA?
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, I THINK THERE
IS A NUMBER OF US WHO FEEL LIKE
YOU COULD HAVE HAD A MORE STEADY
DRUMBEAT OF SANCTIONS JUST SORT
OF RATCHETING UP WEEK AFTER
WEEK.
AND THAT WHEN WE MADE THE
DECISION, WHICH I THINK REFLECTS
WHERE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE,
THAT WE WEREN'T GOING TO SEND
AMERICAN SONS AND DAUGHTERS TO
FIGHT FOR UKRAINE, THAT WE HAD A
RESPONSIBILITY TO USE THOSE
SANCTIONS AS OUR MUSCLE, AND I
THINK THAT WE COULD HAVE DONE
MORE, CERTAINLY NAMING OF
OLIGARCHS, NAMING OF THEIR WIVES
AND MISTRESSES, SANCTIONING
THEM, SEIZURE OF MATERIAL,
THINGS THAT WOULD HAVE CREATED
THE STEADY DRUMBEAT.
IT WAS NOT THE DECISION MADE BY
THE ADMINISTRATION BUT I
SYMPATHIZE WITH ZELENSKYY, HE'S
TRYING TO DO EVERYTHING HE CAN
AND NOT WAITING FOR A WEAPON OF
MASS DESTRUCTION TO BE LANDING
ON THE HEADS OF HIS PEOPLE.
>> IF THERE ARE PRODUCTIVE TALKS
AND I USE THAT WORD LIGHTLY, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT WOULD EVEN
MEAN, IF TALKS ARE ONGOING,
SHOULD SANCTIONS OR NEW
SANCTIONS WAIT WHILE TALKS ARE
ONGOING?
>> THAT'S FAIR.
I THINK WE NEED TO TAKE OUR CUES
FROM PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY, RIGHT?
HE WAS ASKING FOR MORE SANCTIONS
MAYBE 48 HOURS AGO.
LET'S SEE WHAT HE'S ASKING FOR
NOW THAT THERE SEEMS TO BE SOME
POSITIVE MOVEMENT ON
NEGOTIATIONS.
YOU KNOW, WE NEED TO TAKE OUR
CUES FROM THE HEAD OF THIS
COUNTRY THAT IS BEING ATTACKED,
BUT I DO THINK THAT WE HAVE TO
ACTUALLY SEE SOME ACTION FROM
THE RUSSIANS BEFORE WE SORT OF
HAVE A CELEBRATION THAT MAYBE
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF THE
END.
>> THAT'S A GREAT POINT.
JUST BECAUSE THEY SAY THEY WILL
RADICALLY REDUCE THEIR TROOP
PRESENCE AROUND KYIV AND
CHERNIHIV, DOESN'T HAPPEN UNTIL
IT HAPPENS AND JOHN KIRBY AT THE
PENTAGON SAYS THEY HAVEN'T SEEN
ANY EVIDENCE OF IT YET, BUT
WE'RE WATCHING IT VE